There are certain things we see everyday,
and never give a second thought about their history.
But with a little digging, the evolution of everyday objects can be shocking!
If you are a first time viewer, click the red "subscribe" button and enjoy!
Today we are reviewing ten regular objects that look nothing like they used to!
Sunglasses.
Before people were using their sunglasses to look cool indoors, they actually served a purpose!
These are the oldest pair of sunglasses ever found and believed to bee 800 years old!
They were designed by Inuits to help protect their eyes from the light that reflected off the ice and snow.
The light from this snow could get so DANGEROUS that it could actually blind people!
Thankfully, we have a more attractive way to keep the sun out, and look cool at the same time!
Keys.
Metal keys have certainly evolved over the years, but are quickly becoming obsolete,
thanks to technology.
The first versions of metal keys were simpler than what we see today, and
since having something worth locking up was uncommon in ancient times, having a
key became more of a status symbol than anything else.
These days people have so many keys, they can't keep up with them.
Not to mention the hundreds of hotel keycards they probably have lying around.
Toilet paper.
Could you imagine wiping your bottom with a rock? Well, that's exactly what scientists think that these ceramic
disks were used for.
It is believed that ancient Romans used hard sponges dipped in vinegar on a stick to clean up after using the
restroom.
But, because many of these ceramic disks have been unearthed in several Greek and Roman latrines, it's an
easy conclusion that they were also used as ancient toilet paper.
Thankfully, there have been many advances in this department!
High Heels.
High heels fist poped up in histoy around 3500 B.C.,
and the have several transformations since.These pair of heels from ancient Rome and Greece were known as
"Buskins", and were worn by stage performers to help differentiate the social class of individual characters.
In the Middle Ages, high heels made of wood known as "pattens", were slipped on so nobles wear their expensive
shoes clean of mud and street litter.
These days, high heels are worn by men and women who wish to spice up an outfit with the sultry footwear.
Maps.
Considering hundreds of years ago many believed the world was flat.
It shouldn't be surprising that maps look completely different, this first entry map shows an Earth that has
much more land than water.
The America's aren't even on it.
It wasn't until the late 1600s that we see a map that is closer to the one  we use today and modern times we
don't even use paper maps.
Most of the time we rely on our cell phones to tell us where to go.
Cars
One of the first cars to hit the road was this 1.1 horse power carriage
that was invented in 1886.
Just look at the difference in style and the difference in horse power to what we see today.
This car featured 3 tires and a rear engine, and apparently they believed a stick was
the best way to steer. The car has evolved so much that now, 130 years later, we have
over 500 times more horsepower, and luckily for us, a steering wheel.
Apple computers.
In 1976, one of the world's now most famous and lucrative tech companies was born.
Apple, and their first product was the Apple 1 computer.
It looks like something a kid could throw together at their local high school,
but it was considered a huge technological advancement back in the '70's.
Thanks to Steve Wozniak's and Steve Job's innovation, we now have Iphones and Macbooks
that put the early Apple computer to shame.
Socks.
These days, most people wouldn't be caught dead wearing socks with sandals,
but that wasn't the case 1600 years ago.
In fact, these ancient woolen socks were made by the Egyptians to specifically wear with
sandals. Considering there probably weren't many footwear choices in 400 A.D.,
we can forgive the ancient Egyptians for this fashion faux pas.
Bra.
There is nothing about the words "breast pouches" that sounds appealing.,
but this is what bras were made of hundreds of years ago.
This bra from Austria is thought to be around 500 years old.
Notice the pouch like shape, and the lack of underwire. And, there doesn't seem to be any adjusting straps,
which means this bra was custom made for its owner. Bras in modern times are still considered torture devices
much like this one probably was, but at least they are much more attractive.
Condoms.
We often hear of the crazy ways people used to prevent birth before condoms were invented,
but we don't often hear about what these original condoms were made from, or what they looked like.
That is, until now.
This reusable condom is around 370 years old, and is made from sheep skin.
That looks terrifying, and not pleasurable at all. The instructions have been preserved, and
call for it to be cleaned with warm milk to prevent venereal disease.
Ooh, yikes.
Are you happy that these regular objects looked nothing like they used to?
React in the comment section below, and don't forget to like this video, and subscribe to "The Things".